[Music]
hey there Jimmy here and hello again for
me Heather on an earlier episode we
spoke about harnessing the power of
machine learning with cloud ml engine
today we look at how we can derived
insights from unstructured text using
Google cloud natural language a Google
cloud machine learning API will also run
through a quick demo of the self-paced
lab where will ask the cloud natural
language API to extract entities from a
snippet of text let's get to it so I
have a question for you how often do you
look at online reviews when choosing a
restaurant all the time especially when
I'm visiting a new city so do i well as
valuable as these insights are to you as
a consumer good or bad imagine the value
to a business offering the product or
service absolutely from online reviews
social media posts blogs forums and
emails are so many ways to connect the
written word think of the amount of
communication data generated by call
centers as well a wealth of business
critical information just waiting to be
extracted an example of how this can be
helpful in the real world is let's say
you're a business and you need to get
real-time answers to questions like are
my customers happy what is being said
about our business or how well is our
product or service being received this
is where natural language processing is
so valuable as it allows machines to
analyze huge volumes of data that humans
never could Google cloud natural
language reveals the structure and the
meaning of text by offering powerful
machine learning models in an
easy-to-use REST API this API brings you
the same machine learning technology
that powers Google's ability to find
answers in Google search and is a system
behind Google assistant
you can use the syntax and sentiment
analysis functionalities of cloud
natural language to extract linguistic
information in a block of text as well
as the overall feelings expressed with
it you can also use entity analysis to
return information about known entities
such as public figures landmarks
organizations products and so on
positive negative or neutral sentiments
can be identified by combining sentiment
analysis to these entities - and if
you're in an industry like media or
publishing where you would traditionally
have manually sorted labelled and
categorized content the natural language
API can also automatically sort
documents and content into more than 700
predefined categories for you time for
quick loves and this hands-on lab you'll
use the cloud natural language API to
extract entities like people places and
events from a snippet of text you can
check out the link to start the quick
lab here keep in mind that this will
take about 40 minutes to complete so far
in the lab we've created an API key so
that we can use the analyze entity's
natural language API method with this
method the API can extract entities like
people places and events from text we're
going to try out the entity analysis
with the sentence Michelangelo carpaccio
Italian painter is known for the calling
of st. Matthew first we're building our
request to the natural language API in
the request Chaisson file in the cloud
shell editor we can then pass the
request body along with the API key
environment variable to the natural
language API with this curl command the
response shows us the entity type
metadata in this case a Wikipedia URL
and salyanz' the indices of where the
entity appears in the text from 0 to 1
and with that we've sent our first
request to the cloud natural language
API so that brings us to an end of
another episode we hope you enjoyed it
if you found some cool ways to apply the
natural language API we'd love to hear
from you and make sure to check out the
link where you can apply what you've
learned using the 300 of our free trial
credit on Google cloud platform here all
of our additional training resources are
linked below thanks for watching and see
you soon